o Olá meu nome é bravo eu estou aqui
hoje para falar pra vocês um pouquinho
sobre a criatividade e esse poder de ir
além a criatividade como um dos caminhos
para ir além Por que ao longo desses
dois dias no Sedex nós vamos ver muitas
outras possibilidades mas para mim foi
esse o caminho escolhido até hoje eu não
sei se eu fui escolhida pela
criatividade o seu a escolhi com campo
de estudo mas que aos poucos ela foi
chegando de mansinho na minha vida por
meio de um livro por meio de uma
palestra o meio uma de uma disciplina
depois sim por meio de estudos
sistemáticos e ao longo da minha vida eu
fui vendo que no meu TCC eu pesquisei
história da arte
o interessava eram os artistas criativos
no mestrado me debrucei sobre as novas
mídias as novas tecnologias mas para
pesquisar duas mães que fizeram blog
completamente diferente de tudo que
existe na época e no doutorado eu fui
pesquisar a criatividade do professor
universitário e assim me debruçando
sobre essa área do conhecimento que a
psicologia ela estudada desde os anos 50
e quando vejo a criatividade como um
caminho parecer além Eu sempre me
pergunto o que que é ir além Por que que
a gente tá falando de poder eu acho que
o ser humano nessa busca contínua pelo
Divino que há dentro dele ele quis ser
onisciente e ao saber de todas as coisas
ele pesquisou muito a tecnologia
trazendo ferramentas de buscas e nos
trazem de fato o conhecimento muito
escondido ele que serão represente e
hoje as redes sociais e todos os nossos
mecanismos disponíveis nos permite
E aí mais legal mesmo tempo mas quando a
gente fala de se poder da onipresença na
onisciência e onipotência nós
descobrimos que o divino que há dentro
de nós Ele ainda está muito adormecido E
por que que eu falo isso porque quando
nós vemos um contexto de Brasília de
mundo hoje nós temos de fato um avanço
tecnológico avançado maravilhoso com
pontos de inflexão para os próximos anos
muita desejados como primeiro
transplante de órgãos feitos
completamente na tecnologia 3D já tem aí
os transplantes de fígado mundo
estruturados muito muito pesquisados nós
temos aí os primeiros carros com a
impressão totalmente em 3D nós temos da
economia 10 por cento do nosso PIB
esperavam circular por tecnologia blocos
em mostrando o que que eles cenário de
ficção científica de fato estão fazendo
parte da nossa vida turismo espacial
celulares implantáveis tudo isso
as peças nos agora mas por outro lado
nós temos aí a depressão como uma
epidemia uma pandemia muito maior do que
o que nós estamos vivendo com
coronavírus nós temos no Reino Unido o
ministério criado para cuidar
especificamente da depressão e da
Solidão das pessoas nós temos agora 800
milhões de pessoas que implicam contexto
tecnológico não tem acesso sem quer a
luz elétricas 820 milhões de pessoas que
não têm o alimento as camisas todos os
dias então nós estamos sendo criativos
em vários Campos da nossa vida mas
muitas outras áreas estão carentes de
projetos de iniciativas e de atitudes
que possam promover o bem comum e quando
eu trago isso para você se eu falo de
uma habilidade que é considerada a mais
desejada pelo mercado de trabalho então
quando a gente fala criatividade nos
dias de hoje as empresas não
eu vou passar a escrever o quê Porque
tudo muda muito rapidamente essa
habilidade pelo fórum econômico mundial
a figura em terceiro lugar ficando atrás
somente de pensamento crítico e
resolução de problemas complexos e é
muito pouco tempo em 2015 ela segurava
em 10º lugar então sim não tem por onde
fugir mas precisaremos ser mais
criativos nas nossas vidas e o que que é
ser criativo literatura vai nos dizer e
criatividade tem a ver com emergência de
algo que é considerado o novo útil ou
estatisticamente em frequente e que pode
promover mudanças no nível maior porque
a criatividade ela é valorizada ela é
julgada e ela é discutida pelos pares e
o quê que é a criatividade criatividade
no campo científico tá ligado ao a
capacidade que nós temos de resolver
problemas e GM simples ou complexos
emergindo daí a última original que seja
aprovado por Paris
a cidade tem sempre essa dimensão também
social e no nosso dia a dia nós sabemos
que ela pode estar ligada a arte assim
mas que acima de tudo ela tem um poder
de mudança muito grande nas nossas vidas
Nós Diante de alguma coisa criativa é
como se a nossa fonte fosse conectada
com aquele que está criando a gente se
inspira a gente tem vontade de tirar os
nossos projetos do Papel qual suave vai
nos lembrar de quatro dimensões que
precisam estar muito alinhados para os
projetos que vão atender as próximas
gerações a primeira delas é a vertente
contextual Ou seja a mente é como nós
compreendemos e nós aplicamos nossos
conhecimentos e além de tudo que nós
estudamos tem a ver com a nossa
capacidade de estabelecer networking e
relações muito favoráveis que possam
ampliar esse conhecimento nós temos aí
conhecimento técnico em todos os pontos
do mundo EA dimensão contextual ela faz
com que isso possa ser alinhado para os
o projeto Mas além disso tem a vertente
emocional que tem a ver com coração que
como nós integramos desses processos que
são mentais com os nossos pensamentos e
sentimentos e nos relacionamos de
maneira saudável com nós mesmos e com os
outros de nada vale ter conhecimento
técnico se não soubermos nos relacionar
com as pessoas à nossa volta a terceira
vertente a vertente inspirada que a alma
que tem a ver como nós usamos o Nosso
propósito de vida a nossa
individualidade para trabalhar com
propósito de vida compartilhado e que
vai atingir muitas pessoas eo bem comum
e a quarta vertente é a vertente física
tem a ver com o nosso corpo de nada
adianta toda a nossa boa vontade em
criar projetos que transforma e
resistência se nós não nos voltarmos
para nós mesmos e respeitarmos o nosso
corpo a nossa respiração a nossa
Como está o nosso bem-estar pessoal E
isso tem a ver com o nosso alto cuidado
somente quando nós nos olhar entendemos
a nossa necessidade a gente pode ser
capaz de olhar para as necessidades do
mundo entendendo desses processos nesses
projetos dessa nova forma de estar no
mundo que está se apresentando para nós
Nesse contexto das novas tecnologias nós
vamos compreendendo que a criatividade
tem essa capacidade de unir esses quatro
aspectos essas quatro item quando a
gente consegue desacelerar um pouco mais
e se manter observadores da nossa rotina
o que que ele chama atenção Quais são as
nossas dores Quais são os problemas que
a gente Gostaria de resolver em nós
mesmos e consequentemente no mundo o que
você tem algo que dói em mim dói também
e você ou senão em você vai sem alguém
que você conhece você vai ser uma ponte
um ela que vai multiplicar alguma coisa
que vai chegar até aí
eu e nessa medida os projetos criativos
eles vão tô vendo essa pequena União o
que tem um conceito de luz Robin sobre
criatividade que me atrai bastante ela
fala assim a criatividade eh quando eu
mergulho na minha fonte e ao mergulhar
na minha fonte aguenta em contato também
com a sua ali não tem mais onde começa
um e termina o outro porque a fonte é
sempre a mesma no fim das contas Todos
nós somos expressões individuais dessa
unicidade que é muito maior então não
gosto de pensar muito nisso que quando
eu estou sendo criativa eu vou conseguir
impactar e trazer a mudança na vida de
alguém e essa pessoa não vai ser
criativa como eu fui ela vai ser
criativa como ela é isso é o mais bonito
do processo ela vai se inspirar e a
partir do arcabouço das ideias ela vai
movimentar aquela energia num novo
projeto que vai movimentar outras
pessoas
e nós temos um presente de transformação
quando a gente consegue ir além nem que
seja um pouquinho nem que seja Não estou
falando de realizar Grandes projetos que
resolveram a questão da fome no mundo eu
não estou falando de projetos que vão
mudar a realidade de grandes comunidade
e se for melhor ainda porque potencial a
gente tem ferramentas a gente tem e
vontade nos falta mas hoje eu vou falar
de pouquinho eu vou falar de um pequeno
gesto que foi feito e aonde ele chegou e
quando ele chegou no seu. Como ele foi
voltando e foi sendo multiplicado então
eu vou dar nome aos personagens porque
eles são importantes dessa história Dona
Neide a mãe de um grande amigo meu
professor Cláudio Delamare e ao receber
os pouquinhos durante o dia ela tinha
essa vontade de multiplicar com as
pessoas que ela sentiu vontade uma
dessas pessoas estavam enfrentando a
corrigem isolada em profunda isolamento
social
o talit todos os dias e a ouvir a
mensagem ela foi se fortalecendo e
quando ela foi se fortalecendo e ela
venceu a cozinha ela teve uma ideia
muito criativa por sinal ela fez um bolo
delicioso muito gostoso com aqueles
personagens um topo de bolo lindo em que
ela colocava a família dela a família da
dona Neide inclusive com cachorrinho que
faz parte dessa história e mandou uma
mensagem de pouquinho em pouquinho nós
vencemos a corrida dona Neide recebeu
esse bolo ficou muito feliz e me ligou
dizendo você gostaria de ganhar um
pedaço de bolo aí no seu dia eu estou
pensando em mandar o Rodrigo levar aí
para você Rodrigão grande amigo da
família dela
e o que você não imagina aquele aquele
dia era aniversário do meu esposo com
esse aconteça de quarentena nós tínhamos
pensado em tudo nós temos pensado no
almoço especial no cartão não-presente
mas estava faltando uma única coisa que
era um bolo e eu estava no momento com
celular na mão pensando assim como eu
vou fazer para fazer chegar um bolo aqui
nesse dia de hoje eu vou passar na
Confeitaria vou fazer isso mas eu dou
aula e tal de repente meu telefone toca
e quem que era a criança é verdade meu
Tele Sena um pedaço de bolo e não era
qualquer pedaço de bolo era um pedaço de
bolo que tinha uma história Por Trás uma
história muito carinhosa muito criativa
de generosidade de partilha de vontade
de viver e de superar os desafios aquele
bolo quando eu recebi ele na minha casa
quando eu olhei para ele e com Ted ali
do lado para gravar eu falei caramba
isso a ir além e a gente entender o que
está nas nossas mãos não é nada tão
grandioso
e é grandioso Sim mas só vai se
manifestar Quando a gente tiver coragem
de acessar nossa fonte de criativa então
uma mensagem que eu deixo do dia de hoje
é não tenhamos medo porque quando nós
formos além nós vamos encontrar outras
pessoas que tá foram E aí nós fazemos
memória todos esses aprendizados que eu
finalizo agradecimento a todas as
pessoas que tornaram essa caminhada
possível aos nossos familiares aos meus
amigos ao IESB que hoje é o meu campo de
trabalho aos meus alunos aos professores
coordenadores diretores e Corretores e
principalmente essa equipe que deu conta
de produzir e de cuidar de cada detalhe
desse trabalho que agora acontece eu
agradeço a Professora Eunice Soriano de
Alencar e professora Denise Soares e são
minhas aventuras na área de criatividade
agradeço a todas as pessoas que cruzaram
o meu caminho até aqui com muitos
projetos inspiradores um agradecimento
especial ao Felipe Ataíde que
representou o caminho da
e a Gabriela Godinho que me ajuda a
perseverar nele e Thiago Humberto e
Gustavo árvores que trazem o projeto da
do congresso da Felicidade da cidade
escola ayni Gustavo Tanaka e São pessoas
que estão caminhando logo à frente que
me inspiram profundamente a todos muito
obrigada e